FOR YEARS WE'VE ALL WATCHED
CELEBRITIES ACCEPTING AWARDS
GET PLAYED OFF BY
THE HOUSE ORCHESTRA
WHEN THEIR SPEECH RUNS ON
TOO LONG.
MY PARENTS WERE REALLY
DISAPPOINTED
WHEN I DROPPED OUT
OF SCHOOL FOR THAT YEAR,
BUT I FELT LIKE I REALLY JUST
NEEDED TO FIND MYSELF.
WORD ?
BUT THEN, YOU KNOW,
I WAS LIKE, YOU KNOW WHAT ?
LET ME JUST GO TO HOWARD LIKE
MY FATHER, YOU KNOW ?
WELL, THEN, MY GIRLFRIEND
GINA, SHE CALLED ME UP,
SHE SAID, "GIRL, YOU HAVE
GOT TO GET DOWN TO EMORY,
DOWN TO HOTLANTA !
I WAS LIKE GINA,
NUMBER ONE,
WHY ARE YOU CALLING ME UP,
TRYING TO CONFUSE ME ?
YOU KNOW SPELMAN'S
IN ATLANTA, TOO.
SECOND OF ALL, YOU KNOW I'M
VACILLATING HERE, TRYING TO--
WITH "THE WRAP IT UP BOX,"
YOU'VE GOT THAT SAME POWER,
RIGHT IN YOUR POCKET.
SO THEN I JUST WENT TO HOWARD,
WHERE I MAJORED IN SOCIOLOGY,
AND MADE A LOT OF FRIENDS
AND HAD A REALLY GOOD TIME !
SO THAT WAS COLLEGE,
HOW ABOUT YOU ?
FROM THE MAKERS OF
THE HOME STENOGRAPHER COMES
"THE WRAP IT UP BOX" !
IT'S LIKE BEING THE DIRECTOR
OF AN AWARDS SHOW
EVERYWHERE YOU GO !
( pounding gavel )
YOUNG MAN, YOU'VE BEEN FOUND
GUILTY BY A JURY OF YOUR PEERS.
THE CRIME YOU'VE COMMITTED
WAS VERY SERIOUS,
AND BEFORE I SENTENCE YOU,
I'D LIKE TO SAY A FEW WORDS
ABOUT YOUR ARREST RECORD--
WHAT THE HELL ?
YO, THE SIGN
IS REAL SIMPLE, "B",
IT SAYS, "WRAP IT UP."
WRAP THAT
SHIT UP, "B" !
I DON'T THINK THAT'S
A GOOD IDEA.
MAN, YOU WANT SOME TOO ?
YOU'D BETTER
WRAP IT UP !
( pounding gavel )
YOU'D BETTER WRAP
THAT GAVEL UP, "B" !
THAT'S WHAT I'M
TALKING ABOUT.
THAT'S WHAT
I WAS TELLING YOU.
WITH "THE WRAP IT UP BOX,"
THINGS WILL COME TO AN END
AT THE PERFECT TIME...
WHENEVER YOU WANT
THEM TO.
I'M GONNA ROCK IT TONIGHT !
HAVE YOU EVER
FELT THIS IN YOUR LIFE ?
I'M TAKING YOU ON
A JOURNEY, GIRL !
( moaning )
PSYCH !
PSYCH, YOU THOUGHT
I WAS DONE, DIDN'T YOU ?
IT AIN'T OVER.
( music playing )
FOR REAL ?
NOT EVEN CLOSE ?
NOT EVEN CLOSE.
HOLD ON, NOW, HANG IN
THERE WITH ME.
HOW ABOUT THAT ?
HEY,
CAN YOU READ ?
WRAP IT UP.
YOU NEED
TO WRAP IT UP !
WRAP IT UP !
( moaning )
THAT'S A WRAP !
WOO !
"THE WRAP IT UP BOX,"
IN STORES NOW !
AVAILABLE AT ALL WALDBAUM'S.
♪ STOP SKIPPING YOUR
REMEDIAL CLASS ♪